ALEKSANDRA FAUST: Hello.
It's really great
to speak here today.
I want to share with you
today a story about how
I broke a social norm being
a wife, with my husband Eric.
Eric and I met--
we worked together,
he's also a software engineer.
Really great guy, very quiet,
introvert, very supportive.
He also has a
passion for history.
In fact, he published two
history books on civil war.
We started dating, we
got engaged-- we actually
got engaged here in
Chicago on the river
walk under the water
cannon, so Chicago
has a special spot in my heart.
But after we got married,
I started first asking him,
and slowly pressuring him, and
so on, to go to grad school.
And that's not something that he
had in his sphere of interests,
as I mentioned, history
was his passion as a hobby.
And he was happy with his
job, didn't see a reason
why to do it.
But I kept going and going,
I was getting frustrated.
I was really starting
to feel trapped.
And I didn't understand
why that was happening.
And I was thinking,
what was going on?
And it occurred to
me, I really didn't
want him to go to grad
school as much as I
wanted to go to grad school.
And him going to grad
school would give me
permission to do it.
I wonder why is that?
I was raised being told you
can do anything you want,
you can be whoever
you want to be,
and there I was expecting my
husband to go to grad school
so I can do it.
And I looked around
myself, and I
realized I didn't have a
single example, a single role
model, where wife had higher
education than husband
in a relationship.
Nobody back at that time.
And I was like, and why not?
Seriously, what difference
does it make, right?
If that's going
to make me happy,
this is what I want for
myself and my dreams, why not?
And he was very
supportive of that,
so I enrolled in grad school.
I went to the University of
Illinois, great two years.
I graduated, and
eventually that landed
me a job in Sandia National Labs
to work on their space program.
Which, again, was my
dream since I was a kid,
I wanted to work on the space
program, the whole cosmos
and Carl Sagan deal.
But growing up in
Serbia where I was,
that was not going to happen.
So it was an amazing
experience, and I was happy.
I was able to do that.
Now things were
not always as easy.
I want to share my
second story to you
about being an immigrant and
coming to the United States.
I was born and raised in
Serbia, as I mentioned.
And when I was in
college, the country
was engulfed in a civil war.
And civil war brought
crime and corruption.
In particular, things
were difficult for my dad,
who was a full time professor
at university there.
And he witnessed a
lot of corruption
that he was not
participating in,
so it was becoming
very dangerous for him.
Our house was bugged,
we were followed,
it was becoming
a safety concern.
So he made an
unsettling decision
to immigrate to
the United States.
It was a journey for
dignity and safety.
Very unsettling decision, in
particular if you consider
that he did not speak English.
These are my parents here.
So next several years he
spent taking English classes
during the day, cleaning
restaurants and working
in the kitchen at night.
My mom spoke some
English, so she
was able to work as a cashier
in a Dunkin' Donuts shop.
My brother was a
freshman in college.
So finances were tight.
But as my dad said, honest
labor, no shame in that.
Life is good, right?
We know why we came here.
And then my mom started
to lose her eyesight.
It started getting worse, and
worse, and got to the point
that she couldn't recognize the
bills anymore, the money bills.
Which she needed for her job.
So she lost her job.
She lost her health
insurance with it.
Then she started not
being able to wake up.
She was sleeping
longer and longer time,
she was almost in a coma.
Eventually it turned out that
she had a massive brain tumor.
She was promptly
operated on, University
of Michigan Ann Arbor.
It was a 12 hour surgery.
My dad was on her side when she
woke up, and she looked at him
and said, nice to see you,
I haven't seen your face
in months.
They both started crying.
She made a full
recovery, thankfully.
My parents paid
the hospital bill
with their lifetime savings
and by selling our family
home in Serbia.
It is at that time that
I graduated from college
and joined them
here in the States.
So I came to the States
with no references
and from a school with
no name recognition.
I took the first
software engineering
job that was offered to me.
And there I was, 22 years of
age, making $23,000 a year,
and being a breadwinner
in the family.
I also worked at night as
a waitress in a bistro,
and on the weekends I was
working in a [? dining ?]
hall as a server.
And one night I
was in the bistro,
and one of the customers
was upset for some reason,
and he took the liberty
of taking that on me
and slapped me on the back.
I went to the owner of
the restaurant, told
him what happened, and he
said, what do you expect?
What do you want me to do?
You're an immigrant and you
cannot expect the same rights
as everybody else.
You've got to settle for less.
And I looked at him and
I said, I do not settle.
My waitressing career
ended that night.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
I decided to focus on
software engineering.
My parents eventually learned
the language, and both of them
are now university professors
here in the States.
And I was able to start
my own family, right.
Things are going great with
Eric and I. And we had our son.
And this is my
third story to you
as how motherhood
shaped my career.
So this is my son.
He was born very high energy
boy, great sense of humor,
loves to build things,
loves mechanical stuff.
That kid knew every elevator
door and what kind of mechanism
the elevator doors had,
when he was little,
just loved that stuff.
He was really great.
He was six years old there.
But then we started
to notice that he
had a hard time learning social
cues and social behavior.
And we started to grow
concerned about that,
so we took him
tested-- to be tested,
and he was diagnosed with
an Asperger's syndrome.
For those of you who
don't know, Asperger's is
a form of the autism.
The kids can be bright,
can be highly talented
in math, dadada, but
they have a hard time
learning social behavior from
observing an interaction.
So it was a scary time.
We didn't know what to do.
We started working
with a therapist,
and the therapist introduced us
to a concept of Social Stories.
There's an example here.
Social Stories are ways to
teach kids on the spectrum
how to learn social behavior by
breaking it into small steps.
And she went to
proceed to teach us--
or to teach him how to greet
people because that's something
that he wasn't doing.
And this is how it went,
she said, step number one,
if you see a person and it
is the first time in the day.
Step number two, you
turn towards them.
Step number three, you
look them in the eye.
Step number four, you smile.
Step number five, you
say hi or you say hello.
And that worked, he actually
started greeting people.
And Eric and I looked
at each other and said,
that is an algorithm.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
If I was going to write a
program as how to greet people,
that's pretty much what
it would look like.
Right?
There would be some routines
behind it, but that's about it.
So it was like, OK, we got this.
We can do this.
And I don't mean to oversimplify
and undermine autism
by any means, It's
not that simple.
But at least in that little
area with the Social Stories,
we got this.
We're empowered, we know
how to handle this thing.
But then I started
thinking, OK, we
can keep teaching him these
social behaviors one by one,
on case by case basis, but
then what we really want
is to get us out of the loop.
We want him to be able to
learn the behavior by observing
what's happening, and
trying, and learning
from mistakes, and so on.
And I said, OK, if
there is analogy
between Social Stories and
the algorithms on this side,
can I use some
expiration-- inspiration
from artificial intelligence
and machine learning to see
how they can help on that side.
Because that's what
I'm going to do.
I am going to learn
anything there
is to learn about artificial
intelligence and machine
learning.
I'm going to go back to school
and get my doctoral degree.
The other reason for
getting doctoral degree
is that at that time I was
managing a large system
integration which required
lots of meetings, lots
of coordination, lots of travel
and so on, and at that point
my son really needed me
to be there and take him
to the doctors.
And I needed something where
I can have more flexibility.
So going back to school would
A, help me kind of inspire
how to deal and get him to
the ultimate goal, and B,
give me flexibility to still do
fulfilling and interesting work
where I have more flexibility
over what I'm doing.
So that's what I did.
I enrolled at University
of New Mexico,
and I learned about this method
called reinforcement learning.
And what reinforcement
learning does is,
it teaches optimal behavior.
And the way it does
that is you have a robot
or an agent that has sensors,
can sense the environment,
it can move in the environment,
it experiments, sees what's
happening, makes observations,
is-- how the change--
if it does something, what
was the effect of the action?
And receives the feedback that
is how good or bad the action
is, reward or a punishment.
And based on that
experimentation
it develops an optimal,
or near optimal,
behavior that maximizes long
term benefits for the agent,
even though it can make costly
mistakes at the beginning.
And it was fascinating.
It was like, I got to do this,
I absolutely-- this is perfect.
So my advisor got me connected
with the professor who
presented me with the
problem of the quadrotor
delivering coffee.
Now quadrotors are
non-linear systems.
Which means that when
you do something to them,
you push, give a
force, give an input,
the connection between what
you do to them and what happens
is described with a non-linear
differential equation.
Which means it's
very hard to compute,
or if you're going to
do it computationally,
it's very computationally
expensive.
The second problem
with the quadrotors
is that when you have an
airplane or a fixed wing
aircraft, you push
it and it glides
and you don't need to do
anything, it just flies.
What happens with a
quadrotor if you let it go?
It just falls down, right?
In order to make
the quadrotor fly,
you need to provide
input all the time,
150 to 100 times a second.
And these are the calculations
that are computationally
expensive to do.
Now when you add a
cup of coffee that you
don't want to spill while
you're delivering it,
that kind of brings
the complexity
to a whole new level.
And he wanted to do it with
the reinforcement learning.
I said, yes, I'm going to do it.
I have no idea what I'm
doing, but I'm going to do it.
So what happened then,
over the next three months,
I went and learned
anything I could
get a hold of about
reinforcement learning.
I did tons of
experiments, simulations,
it failed, It didn't
work, try again,
more simulation, try
again, dadada, didn't work,
and finally I got it working.
Yes.
So reinforcement
learning at the time
assumed that you have several
actions, maybe 10 here.
You can just go straight, back,
left, right, maybe up and down,
and that's about it.
In order to make
the quadrotor work
without spilling
the cup of coffee,
I had to consider over
one million actions
at every 50 times a second.
But it worked.
So the rest of my dissertation
was making this more efficient
and proving that it actually
did what I claimed it to do
and was not going to
crash into something.
And yeah, that was
my dissertation.
So-- in three sentences.
So that eventually
landed me a job in Google
that I'm doing what is
learning behaviors, right?
Making robots learn behavior
and that remains passion.
Is exactly-- I taught robot here
to deliver my cup of coffee.
It is exactly the
same type of thing
that-- that I'm interested
in doing for my son.
Even though, it
remains my passion.
Now I have another
mission in my life.
This is my daughter, who
is eight years old now.
She's a girl with a grit.
She's very creative
and imaginative.
She loves building things.
She's building a robot here
that uses a visual sensor
to sense when
somebody passes, when
there is a motion detected.
There's a basic motion
detector and then waves.
We're back to greeting.
She has a whole plan
of the projects she'd
like to do when she grows up.
She'd like to
build a flying car,
she'd like to build portable
wings, she really likes flying,
she'd like to be
a pilot as well.
So she brought another
mission to my life,
and that's to pave a
smoother path for her.
And it's because of her that I'm
here today talking to you guys,
even though, for
an introverted me,
this is very deeply
uncomfortable and very
unsettling.
So thank you.